what's going on guys hope you had a
great week bitcoin's starting to rebound
a little bit bringing some more
enthusiasm back into the market but the
question is will this last or will it
not we're gonna go ahead and get into
all the on-chain metrics along with many
of the market dynamics don't forget
these weekly unchain metrics are brought
to you by ftx i'll tell you more about
them at the end all right let's get into
this week's update let's see what
exactly is going on with bitcoin and
will this survive to get started first
we see that bitcoin is now trading at
over 23 000 definitely recovering from
some of the past weeks price levels then
if we take a look at the bitcoin network
itself the current market cap is 436
billion dollars we can see that more
than 90 percent of the supply has been
issued and the inflation rate remains at
1.76
the real exchange volume over the last
24 hours is just over 5 billion dollars
and the miners have been paid 21.2
million dollars in 24 hour period to
continue to secure the most
decentralized secure network in the
world bitcoin is down 66 from its
all-time high but it's up about 32
percent or so from the recent lows
then if we compare bitcoin gold and the
s p 500 we see that bitcoin is down 30
over the last 12 months gold and the s p
down as well but over the last two to 10
years bitcoin has drastically
outperformed either one of these assets
next up we can take a look at bitcoin's
price closing history currently sitting
at that 23 000 mark meaning that for 88
of bitcoin's life if you had bought it
and held till today you'd be in profit
and only about 12 of the time or so if
you'd bought it and held till today you
would be underwater
then if we take a look comparing bitcoin
to gold s p 500 nasdaq and tlt we can
see that the compound annual growth rate
of bitcoin at 120
is drastically outperforming any other
assets bitcoin sharpe ratio sitting at
1.03 over a five-year period meaning
that if you put bitcoin into a
diversified portfolio it ends up having
an incredible advantage over most of
these other assets
next up we can go take a look at the
blockwear newsletter put together by
will clemente and the team over there
they do a fantastic job of this every
week and i highly suggest that you check
it out
first up we've got bitcoin reclaiming
the 200 weekly moving average this has
been bitcoin's largest weekly candle
since april when the luna foundation
guard built up their bitcoin reserves
but that's not good enough to simply
clear over that 200 weekly moving
average will points out that bitcoin has
seen one of its furthest deviations from
that 200-day trend in history the only
times it's ever been this far below are
highlighted in the green here then we
can go take a look at the daily price
structure perspective bitcoin pushing
along the range has traded in for the
last month and has retested both the
point of breakout as well as that 200
week moving average at the time of this
writing price looks good for
continuation to the levels above but
invalidation of this idea would be price
going back down into the range
next up we can see that the 28 000 mark
is resistant that would also align with
an underside re-test of short-term
holders cost bases that occurrence has
happened four times in 2018 on the way
down the psychology of this is that
whenever the cost basis is retested
market participants who are underwater
will look to exit the market at
breakeven
will and the block where team they go on
to look at the order books first coming
up with coinbase pointing that there is
a very big skew to the bid side and
there are no major visible clusters of
asks above the 20 000 mark you can also
see that there's a gap in volume showing
the selling on the way down it's very
inefficient due to force selling and
thus there is not much overhead supply
in that area
wilton points out that the ftx spot
shows a very similar profile as well
moving on to the derivatives we see that
the perpetual swap open interest
continues to climb in both absolute and
relative terms indicating a decent size
build up in futures contracts over the
last few weeks and then looking at the
funding rates as a gauge for positioning
aggression they see a mixed regime for
the last month indicating a lack of
conviction of expectations from the
market in aggregate
lastly we can go take a look at
bitcoin's correlation you can see the
correlation the federal funds rate
maintains to be almost perfectly inverse
pairing this with its correlation to m2
money supply highlighting how bitcoin is
a hedge against monetary debasement
and then bitcoin's correlation to the
nasdaq also remaining freakishly high
from the on-chain side of things one
metric that they haven't been talking
about over the last few weeks is
long-term holders those long-term
holders are under pressure to a degree
that has only taken place a few times
before during the 2012 bear market 2015
bear market 2018 bear market and right
now
will defines this as when prices below
long-term holders cost basis and when
coins are being spent by long-term
holders below the price that they
acquired another thing that will hasn't
touched on recently is the ratio of
stable coins market cap relative to the
aggregate crypto market cap whenever the
lower bound or this trend line is tagged
it shows that a lot of capital has been
deployed into the market and there are a
few new marginal buyers left conversely
whenever the ratio reaches the top of
the channel it indicates macro bottoming
and accumulation levels so far the ratio
has worked well and is starting to roll
over indicating that the crypto market
cap is growing faster than stables on a
relative basis
one interesting point that will
concludes with is that there's actually
been a flipping on the exchange side
according to glass node finance now has
dethroned coinbase for having the most
spot bitcoin on their platform make sure
that you go and you subscribe to the
blockwear newsletter you can see the
links in the description or go follow
will and the rest of the team on twitter
they're doing fantastic work and i
continue to learn a ton from them that's
it for this week's update i hope that
you enjoy these they're really fun to
put together and i learn a ton as i
continue to work through all the data
don't forget that these are brought to
you by ftx you can go and click on the
link in the description to learn more
about ftxus they've got very low trading
fees sometimes as much as 85 lower than
their competitors they also have
introduced brand new digital stock
trading which allows you to buy and sell
stocks right next to crypto in your same
account that digital stock trading comes
with no transaction fees and no payment
for order flow meaning they continue to
pursue best pricing go check out ftx us
today you can click on the link in the
description ftx one of the most
innovative companies in the space
continuing to push forward all the
technology all the infrastructure that
will lead to more and more adoption
that's it for this week i'll see you all
next saturday hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time